[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
happy Friday everybody happy Friday been
back to you as well
John Luke we're here apologies for the
delay everyone but we were having some
technical difficult in the PC with yes
this was a pleasant surprise mid in the
week they kind of dropped it on on Steam
so now we're gonna play it Evan if you
don't mind cutting over to the game
we've got some cool instructions and how
you guys can join us there we go exactly
yes so if you play in Halo Reach with us
a few weeks ago then it's the same
method basically we have a steam group
called GameSpot official so at the
bottom we list how you joined you just
go to that URL and you join the GameSpot
group and then you join in this group
chat you click on my name here starters
Crusader and you join game and you
should be able to join in and play with
us you gonna set up the lobby first
though now lobbies all set they should
be able to join I got you and I've got
the chat right here so I can see what
you guys are saying cuz John Luke's
gonna be playing mhm
and we're all gonna hang out and have a
good time I think the ideas will play as
people join in we will play online and
then if enough people join in that we
could switch over to custom stuff we'll
do custom games yeah yeah see you're
monitoring the chat right yeah cool we
will play some like capture the flag
some Slayer yeah some some good old
classic just good times
halo ones always a a weird one with
me it there there's a little bit of like
it's it's not tuned as well as like halo
two or three a reach but there's
something about it that still feels
really good to me yeah totally and it
still it's from what I've played it's
pretty good on pc i saw someone
mentioned earlier that they might that
they didn't have like the announcer
playing which is a very bad bug to have
in a Halo game and I hope that's not the
case
let's see anniversary mixer breach
gametypes Oh interesting so that's the
remember how in reach
they added a bunch of Halo one maps and
that's what came with the anniversary
edition on the 360 yeah so I guess
they've included that it's like a
playlist which makes sense really nice
yeah how's it going Bob Jones good to
see you
david says Blood Gulch is fun times
Blood Gulch is best times any Halo
without a Blood Gulch is missing
something very important interesting
precision flair and Auto Slayer well
that's uh if you want like DMR's or be
ours yeah or the Magnum assault rifle
makes sense if Microsoft is letting
steam play games on their platform will
be will play xbox just our steam games
I'm hoping Microsoft's been doing a lot
of really good stuff with sharing what
they've got and I hope they can you to
do I'm just gonna start a game up just
to just to get it going oh yeah you know
warm up but oh yeah uh the other last
update they gave when they were talking
about Halo one pcs that they straight-up
have said cross play is a thing that's
coming oh like between the council and
the pieces like you confirm they're like
yeah we're working on cross play oh yeah
oh okay that's awesome so there you go
disappointed halo 3 never had Blood
Gulch yeah yeah haha I would serve its
replacement fall is good it's too
vertical for me I'd like for holla that
said I've played that map to death yeah
I don't know if I ever need
mahalo again that map is a lot it plead
it played two differently I felt really
like compact and yeah it's a fun map I
love gravity lifts were really cool and
I like the verticality of it but I think
I've just played that map to death I'm
so excited to get Halo 2 in here I'm
just excited to play Halo again I get
out every time we play Halo because I
just I love it so much it's a good time
uh what is our favorite map overall in
all the Halo all the halos why don't we
go with each game first and then okay
maybe so halo one blood Blood Gulch I
think is a safe bet for me Blood Gulch
sure hang him high I'm gonna say are my
two favorite only because I really like
a shotgun
I actually bloke he really like cheer on
but I wouldn't like its riches right in
it I wouldn't like go out of my way to
actually say it's a good map uh halo to
ivory tower I feel yeah ivory tower
really good midship really good yeah I
like oh wait Battle Creek and Beaver
Creek are also very oh you know what
yeah those are really good um so simple
if we're picking a low one let's say you
would say black ops right I'd say Blood
Gulch its I go I shoot but Sidewinders
also really good that one is also very
good the Blood Gulch I'm gonna stick
with girls
halo 2 uh ivory tower might be my
favorite midship is the one I do best I
have a tower is really good every towers
just a really good map coagulation was a
good Blood Gulch but it's not entirely
Blood Gulch mm-hmm uh I'd agree ivory
tower halo 3 well that we can't move on
from the halo 2 without mentioning
headlong though I really like head
launch all right yeah but Halo 3 and
Halo 3 um
[Music]
actually not no favorite halo 2 matte
block out oh yeah lockouts - my favorite
okay I'll you mentioned walk out to walk
out is by far my favorite halo to map um
[Applause]
then I would say for Halo 3 it's tough
like I'm trying to like avoid being like
like oh you know you want to go for the
gimmies but but also like the remakes I
don't want to investigate the remakes I
kind of want to stick with like the
originals no wonder it yeah the original
maps that are inhale 3 III like Guardian
but it's sort of just a different
version of lock-out yeah it's it's
lockout esque and I don't like it as
much as Locke so much an ascension and -
there's too many good a low man look
Hills got really good mass not really
good maps uh we could probably stop at
three if I'm fine not picking up anybody
looks like I did not tell you a favorite
Haila format about reach oh shoot um you
know what even though there's not much
to it I think sword bass plays really
well - if it's really clean I like how
you've got the different floors there's
a lot of verticality it plays into like
having the jet pack and all that now
sword base might be one of my favorites
breakneck was one of my favorite Hill
mapserver heck yeah God go find Rob yeah
we should we should did we tell Rob we
were playing Halo that's now he didn't
actually that's a good call pelipper we
should we shoulda let Rob know cool if
halo see II got a remake I mean
technically it's got anniversary edition
but I'm gonna be honest I've been
talking about with a couple of people
about this since they put it on on PC
people and playing again but I don't
know if halo anniversary
seee is actually better than you know
the original it I like halo two
anniversaries halo 2 anniversary is very
good but there's something about the the
anniversary version of one that's just
doesn't work it doesn't work for me the
art style is all over the place they put
memes on the computer panels it's it's a
little too much I agree and I kind of
like this like people like all looks
texture less there's textures here but
it's it's that oh it's got it's got a
strong look and it's got it's got a look
of its time it's it's smooth I don't
know it I'm into it
oh yeah maybe like a like a maybe more
geared towards what this is remake I'd
be into it well for me the exciting
thing is more that you can now mod the
PC version
oh yeah they have that like executable
version that's specifically designed for
modding so we can all play cursed halo
and people have been modding a a custom
edition for years they've been like you
know there's all sorts of versions of
Halo that you can play that have like
tweaked it but now people can do that
properly
well good people can do that properly
with Halo all the Halo games not just
custom edition so if anything it's like
hey somebody can make their own graphics
updated version of Halo 3 if they want
it's true uh that'd be kind of cool
brandon hernandez also says we should
not only just tell rob but also persian
version is also very good at halo yes
persians unfortunately
still home today she's been feeling
under the weather all week a bit of a
recovery mode but also David bringing up
this is the dream just getting everyone
in the office - like who's free to just
turn on a halo and join in just because
you know not like all that grenades
losing their physics are wild hello yeah
yeah Battlefront 2 is actually really
kind of good now love that dang it
seven I had a copy since it came out and
I booted up a little while ago she's
kind of check it out yet like you've got
so many different heroes to play now
there are so many maps that they just
add it in uh maybe a battlefront to
community Friday would be an interesting
one if we caught it like on another big
update or something what people want
want the played out with us and I'm down
yeah that's something people are
interested in a good a good time can you
do the reloading glitch with the
controller are you talking about the one
where you kind of like cancel the reload
animation so it doesn't do the whole
thing oh I'm not too familiar with that
it's it's kind of like you you do like a
like a button combination of like
swapping the weapon after the the
magazines actually replaced and it just
skips the tail end of the animation
super big but like like that kind of
thing like for you it is something like
that I'm more of the the halo 2 ones
like the mail i cancelling and all that
but halo one's got some fun stuff the
the one that I I remember getting it
down with reloading like a sniper rifle
with launcher because I remember hearing
the clip still slide out wall I see like
the rocket launcher melee animation
happening like very vividly in my head
so I tried to get it down at one point
double melee works yeah I remember doing
the old super sword lunge into I missed
that oh yeah that was fun you could like
go all the way across the map okay let's
back up here see what we got
is anyone in here yet got a couple
people no one's ready to join yet though
it looks like are you sure you don't
need to actually be in the game because
I think we had to be in like Oh a lobby
to do it like in the custom multiplayer
mod pretty sure you can just cuz that's
the only time I was able to join you
okay I mean I could rest in here saying
if I also join for a minute so if you
guys have joined up into the end of the
chat group you should try to join now
and we'll see if we can get maybe some
like some free-for-all going until more
people are able to show up and yeah yeah
and take it from there they're gonna try
off like the chat in the game it's not
annoying I don't know
[Music]
but I trust that no one will be mean no
but it's not just like people were
inviting enslaved voice-chat you got it
you got voice chat volume down to zero
so he won't even hear it yeah it's true
we do got stream delay i wasn't not set
to the right uh I mean just inherent
stream delay as like I think let's go
say I set it to I thought I so it's a
low latency yeah alright well just chill
for a hot minute see if anyone joins uh
Ben how are you done I'm doing alright
uh this week went by really quick I was
talking about it earlier and me too
I'm literally just sitting here focusing
on Animal Crossing and doom coming out
repeating over and over in my head
counting down the days as they go off so
I can't wait on that though I mean I
there's a there's a like a weird
roguelike game that I've been playing a
lot on Steam that I haven't seen
mentioned too many places it's like
curse the curse of the old gods or curse
of the something gods but it's it's very
good for an early access game and the
amount of content and polish it has so
far it's got like a like a darkest
dungeon art style to it which is really
cool
oh that's cool so I'm playing a lot of
that off and on but yeah
doom is the only thing that's important
this month I understand that but I gotta
have my animal crossing any plans for
the weekend
Brandon asks us I'm probably gonna play
Civ and maybe more of that that
roguelike that I've been messed around
with how can you find the GameSpot group
on Steam so you've got a search Oh the
URL is right there yeah
visit URL but I think you just search
GameSpot official is it actually called
GameSpot officials group or like what
can you RL you search yeah or just
GameSpot official just search that up
and you should be able to just join
gonna it's right here
go on going in there why to join come on
in do that kind of thing gonna call duty
Lyon LA yo yeah howdy come on in
come on in play some halo I can't wait
for III you see some halo infinite
gameplay yeah and also following up
right after that prophet saying if v3
isn't canceled or postponed or something
it's wild out there this this
coronavirus is off-the-chain sick we're
getting people in yeah excellent
and the good thing too we should also
mention with this GameSpot official
group is this is the one we're gonna be
running all of our PC stuff through
Fridays yes if there's any game you ever
want to play with us join this group you
can join through here and all the things
half-life Alex we were talking about
that yesterday well we were playing
Black Mesa because it finally came out
yeah 1.0 we've been prepping ourselves
for that one we're messing around with
some some VR stuff the other day -
Jordan asks us which halo is our
favorite three
I feel like multiplayer wise I like to
the most threes my overall favorite but
I definitely have like the more I've
liked retro actively played - I think
I've liked a greater appreciation for
its certain its speed its speed is its
major key thing
I love three lot and I love reach a lot
a lot for like a complete package a lot
but I think in my mind when I'm like I
want to play Halo 2 multi or I won't
play Halo multiplayer see I just slipped
up and said halo 2 multiplayer because
I'm already thinking about it that's
that's the one I want to go to all the
time but you can't really go wrong with
halo unless you play four or five but I
think eyes aren't even that bad yeah
friends only that [ __ ] that should still
work you should be able to join in yeah
once you're in that channel you do is
right-click on the name and yeah she
like click on my name and then hit like
join you should be able to join that
like join game it's like just drive my
game I like doing that what Stella five
mediocre it wasn't what I was looking
for there is somebody I can see I could
see why people like four and five but
it's not I did not mind for is her sorry
I liked for his campaign it's not
perfect but I like it enough mmm-hmm I
liked 5s multiplayer I thought it was
pretty good however I thought 4s
multiplayer is bad and I thought 5s
campaign is with garbage
Jordan Ford took too much of the
emphasis off of the arena style stuff we
got three people so I think we're gonna
go back then and take them in watch me
take some matchmaking people yeah for
one of these people with me for head
less emphasis on arena stuff and five
had a really big eSports pushed and they
had the Dodge and all that extra
movement stuff that I didn't need I mean
it's it's good improvements but I just
want I just want hail ice what halo oh
yeah I just draw all modes or what do
you think you I think you keep it Slayer
tiny depends on what you want to play
I'll still with fire types for the Maha
objective stuff is primarily its
matching data please wait okay that's a
new I've never seen her go try
battlefront two creamy Friday at the end
of month update comes out because here
is definite
thank you I'm sure everyone parties the
same game data we'll keep an eye out for
certain update it mmm these people might
not have halo installed he'll the one it
oh is that what it said one when I tried
earlier I think so get out of sync put
the data in the sync I don't care if
it's free all right guys well if you
want to play sure it is kind of weird
that you have to like install the games
from inside the game has halo installed
okay I was gonna say I feel like if they
got in here dude that haven't said a
thing is it let you join my party and
then it was just like oh actually you
can try start up a custom even see what
happened custom game if the data's there
because if it's if they don't of a
custom game would be the same I'm
wondering if maybe just somethings
messed up with the hoppers for
matchmaking or something maybe let's do
about live-streaming a single-player
campaign from from Metro the Metro games
our our stream on Friday is mostly
focused on multiplayer stuff sometimes
we'll do like if there's a big new
release yeah they Adam installed it was
just made of the servers they're having
a weird issue maybe the hoppers muscle
or maybe it'll set up after this we'll
do it got a cool a very a very intimate
three-person thing there's a match and
and people would can join mid game yeah
by the way so if you if you want to hop
in you don't need to wait for us to
finish you can just join there are some
questions from Christian do you think
we'll get a GTA 6 announcement soon like
gameplay or trailer uh I mean I don't
know if because people are kind of like
excited because of all the updates that
happened to that Rockstar website that
have like no tie to anything you saw
that oh yeah yeah that that fan made
trailer that was making the rounds that
some some sites chose to some sites
chose to write about as national in a
very misleading way so that was a thing
but yeah I feel like it's some point
we're some point we're gonna get it I
don't know if it'll be this year I don't
know I I feel like we're still a ways
off from seeing new GTA stuff because
right now they've got Red Dead and GTA 5
is still doing pretty well for him I
want to see bully though give me give me
a bully to God waiting for halo 2
anniversary same JJ I'm so excited for
Halo 2 when I can play that again
yeah I wonder they said they're trying
to get them all this year and what was
the amount of what was the time
difference between reach and oh it was
so quick it was like oh what a couple
months yeah
the juggler for card duo is back heck
yeah you can't get rid of us we're here
forever
we got we're back to playing halo
hanging out it's good to see you back
let's go seal I seal a couple of people
from from yesterday cool out we've
chosen to show up and hang out again
makes me really happy
oh damn weed spawn is so instantaneous
but I do appreciate talking about other
games people are excited for yeah Final
Fantasy 7 remake that's at the top of my
list now after that demo I was sold I'm
I'm still hoping to finish I'm gonna do
it you know what I'm calling it I'm
finishing Dragon Quest this weekend and
I'm starting Final Fantasy 7 that's I'm
gonna do I'm gonna stay off of final
fantasy xiv i'll pry myself away from
that and i'm gonna do other rpgs
i want to make it happen so patrick
don't ya it's not a bad joke at all GTA
and bowling are synonymous I'm into it I
felt it what did he miss gameplay wise
from the version yeah you know we've
just kind of been hanging out we did a a
match we've got some people in here now
if anyone else would like to join the
info down there will lead you in but
basically join our GameSpot official
steam group it's the one that we use for
all of our PC stuff with you guys and
and all that and once you join that you
join up in the chat and then you can
right-click on John Luke's name which is
start us crusader and join on in so it's
got joining progress so you can kind of
like Johnny you should just right then
as they're happening yeah ah
Mario Kart 9 dude I would kill for a new
Mario Kart or like updates for a good
one are updates for Mario Kart 8 even
like add more characters you tracks to
the one that's already there that's
really good
a lot more Mario Kart
feel like you're the wise one in John
Luke is the quirky one I think we're
both pretty wise and pretty quirky but I
like where you're going okay
I didn't era Dave you're developing
you've got you've got I it isn't exactly
fair because both of these streams I've
been talking the whole time while John
Luke's been playing but yeah right we're
pretty strong duo I'd say it I'll do it
I'll go for it
I'd ship it yeah yeah see should be a
big three with Halo Infinite metric
crime for hopefully breath with a while
to smash DLC cyberpunk Forza this year
is just wild name an awesome game and I
feel like a lot of that is definitely
due the fact that we're getting the new
consoles and we mentioned it yesterday
to again uh like half of this year is
unknown we don't know what's what's
happening like I said most at all post
e3 this was a lot to think about a lot
of possible a lot of possibilities
as soon as I see the the flamethrower
the first thing I think of is it being
the best weapon for fighting off people
with lag in the PC version because it
just puts damage everywhere and it
doesn't matter what your connection was
like you just end up killing everyone
maybe even yourself
I think the rest of the wild too
probably is gonna be like a twenty20 one
thing yeah I think that's only this year
I don't think it's gonna be this year
but we'll get more information I think
I'm curious what Nintendo's gonna have
this year other than Animal Crossing
it's the only thing we know about that
they have here dream Nintendo
announcements f-zero give me enough zero
give me a new Star Fox give me I'd
really want to hear more about Bayonetta
3 yeah I think I think we're overdue for
Bayonetta stuff so I'm into that but
like I like even if it's just like
here's F zero GX but brought up onto the
switch or here's Star Fox zero but we
took out the motion control so it's
actually playable like I'd be fine with
any of those or even completely near
oh you got someone up above there you
had those those things I want I'm
excited to see what the new smash DLC is
gonna be obviously still pulling for my
boy Travis touchdown
I think he's got chance a rumor of a new
2d Metroid I'm down for that too mmm
yeah there was that whole thing where
they kind of gave a tease at the end of
samus returns for fusion so it's like
they could do it and a remake of fusion
yeah yeah they could do a brand new one
oh that's a good call to a new dead
space would be really really clutch oh I
wouldn't hold out for that one I
wouldn't either but think about how cool
would be I agree I would love that but
Oh miss dead space me too
beta 3 for sure this year more pokemon
DLC yeah more information about
overwatch 2 would be interesting there's
the Pokemon DLC I guess that is true
that's pretty significant um yeah I feel
like overwatch too they just kind of
announced it and then just kind of like
left it may be said like oh we don't
know when it's coming out and I'm like
seems like a really doing outset then
also you know what I realized last night
because I was also talking to some
people about riots FPS game valor --nt
yeah Florent whatever it is you guys
what that game is right
it's just Shadowrun jean-luc they
brought Shadowrun the FPS version back
oh man I like shocker I did too and I
had that like small realization I'm like
oh shoot this is happening to me watch
play shatter on bring it is that even
possible
are you asking me if I'd like to play
Xbox Live's first cross platform video
game a revolution a revolution the ahead
of its time
pave the way I mean if we could find a
way to get to work I'm not against it
even if we can't get other people to
play with us maybe just like elfin run
off the sword
yeah that game was was wild I like to
that game I can't miss cool why is he
playing with a controller when it's on
PC so this is the thing
it's obviously PC you know keyboard and
mouse is like the optimum way to do it
but the thing is the classic halo feel
is in the controller the that's one
answer the other answer is I don't want
to hurt my back by punching over for ya
just don't let it don't you don't want
to hurt John Luke by making him play on
a keyboard and mouse
I agree I'd like to to build a set up
here that makes it easier to do PC stuff
but especially like for example we play
something do you know oh yeah I can't
not yeah I refused to play doing with a
controller but yeah also even when I do
have a proper setup I still prefer
playing Halo with a controller just
weird odd strange even and I know it but
it doesn't stop me from doing it it just
it just feels good Oh David David's all
caps and totally re-download Shadowrun
it's backwards compared what that's not
backwards compatible get out of town of
course it is it was an Xbox published
thing why wouldn't it be yes fair I how
did I miss that Shadowrun was backwards
compatible see I had it on PC I didn't
even have the Xbox I didn't know what
you could play with everyone it's true
either way my windows vista copy of
Shadowrun oh man you know I I'm in an
Amish game for Windows Live I said as a
joke but I was actually surprised when I
got prompted to download it for I was
when all the stuff with GTA 4 was
happening I was like oh [ __ ] I started
off to check and it's like log into
games for Windows Live please yeah like
that service is not around anymore but
there's still some games that never got
rid of its my Dark Souls ended up
getting rid of it
there are a couple other ones that did I
was like oh thank God because everyone's
like Dark Souls cuz they're getting rid
of games live yeah
yeah it's it's playable on Xbox one but
Shadowrun well yeah cuz
backwards-compatible I was like okay
yeah sure maybe into like the the 360
I'm just all over the place
shoot
baby if it's playable on Xbox one wife
we've been unshadowed yet cuz there's
probably no I didn't think anyone would
want to play Shadowrun oh man I was just
like no one would want to play that well
why would that happen I love is there
anyone else in the chat who wants to
play we're just gonna keep going a
Christian also doubles side I feel
foolish I didn't even know and now I
know is that another good maps Wizards
good Wizards fun this is a beauty once I
never I never messed with I played a bit
on some of them like I played the the PC
version of Halo do with your bit but who
is 'red it's only 15 bucks I might just
buy it just to mess around on the
training cuz you definitely can't play
it online anymore right I don't know I
don't know I'm sorry I'm asking you all
these questions that there's no way
you'd have the answer just right at the
rate your hands we'd probably have a
copy foul to run in the lc3 code
actually I'm very sure we have a copy of
it in the end log a my rod Davidson
there's a whole two people who wanna
play shadow run that's enough for a 1v1
that's pretty good that's it bring back
shout around you see how the monster
huddle movie will do same actually oh it
looks weird
umm I have no idea how there's like time
travel in it or something cuz I've seen
people she like travels to like an
alternate reality or dimension yeah I'm
thinking it's like Stargate but Monster
Hunter that sounds like a good pitch
when you say it out loud like that but I
have a feeling that I do not get a turn
out that I don't know if it's gonna turn
out like that bear I'm definitely gonna
watch it dang it I'm all about that
[Music]
oh man
the map infinity is kind of bad yeah the
what infinity was that was the two ships
boarding action literally like across
from each other oh that was I was a cool
concept for a map I don't know that for
the PC version no that was in regular
halo oh okay
I think it was called boarding action I
never really engaged as much inhale once
multiplayer because this is harder game
gauging but I didn't come in a halo
until after two came out so like I was
already just playing toots multiplayer
and I only tried ones multiplayer had a
fun time playing with some friends but
it was like we're all just like let's
just go to two it's better yeah I uh I
really just played like ones campaign
was more what I played I didn't expect
to be into a locust odd one when the
Xbox and Gamecube came out I was like I
remember that like holiday because I was
like I want a Gamecube rat would I want
anything else it's a square it's just
it's got a handle you could take it
anywhere it's built for fun uh and my
dad was like eh oh this Xbox though it's
big it's loud it's obnoxious and I need
to have it cuz it's got driving games on
cool you do that I'll do my it my
GameCube thing Xbox really was like your
dad's yeah I do gaming console uh and
he's he's like because I remember doing
it I'm like ah cool got my Gamecube I
don't even need to worry about this and
I saw him like opening up the Xbox in
the corner and I saw a halo and I didn't
like think about any of the games over
there anything until I saw him playing
them and my gosh yeah that's pretty good
I was like oh man maybe I need to try
these out yeah I had played so much Xbox
it was the best prize
who would have known that a silly
first-person shooter that my dad got on
a whim because it had a car like on the
back of it she's really into driving
games does is this thing would be one of
my favorite FPS games I ever played
crucible you talking about is there a
game called crucible they talk about
destinies multiplayer
although the map I think that I was out
a map crucible
imagine monster Hernandez targets yeah
that's I want that to happen now we got
some some cool green rifling happening
I'm here for it
I found a comment from Xbox and Sharon
is still running servers what what I
assume they just shut those down I
assume they did too but that's one of
those things that you're just like I
probably I'm pretty sure I saw an
article really said that you know you
just like assume that was a thing well
maybe maybe we'll look into this and see
what's going on and maybe get the
Shadowrun back on Shadowrun I'm not
upset at all I'm not upset at than at
all at all no that's pretty good
how can I get invited ah so if you would
like to join please drying we've got
these these instructions on at the
bottom but I can I can say them out loud
basically join the the GameSpot official
steam group and once you do that just
join the chat and you should be able to
right click join on Stardust Crusaders
John Luke and you can join in progress
but basically the steam group is how we
do all of our invites for PC stuff yep
so once you're in there for this you're
in there for anything else we play on
peering into life you're in you can't
leave you're not clouds yeah it's it's
it seems like we're trying to like push
people to join a steam group but really
it's because we're lazy and it's the
easiest way to invite people
it's not even lazy it's like pragmatic
really it's such a headache otherwise so
you have to go through all these other
hoops just like you use menus games in
game like the steam stuff just seems
like it overrides it yeah way easier
exactly
gotta take a bath do that thing get
clean take that bath sir my just clear
my schedule for Shadowrun oh it's it's
Dave David he's way into it David I
swear if we streamed shadow running you
don't show up I'm gonna be so mad look
the one person who was really really
stoked on it just and then he ditches us
she found a person who just streamed
Shadowrun all the time and that's that's
what was hanging out it was kind of
weird though because I I think you're
like one of the only people I've ever
like talked about anonymous because my
experience playing that game was I
bought it not realizing that it was just
online basically me too
and so I just did the training over and
over I thought there was gonna be a
single-player mode I was dumb and didn't
know yeah but I saw had fun with it got
me to I I actually played a fair amount
with bots yeah you know well that's the
other thing too we got spawns Cohen for
MK oh yeah that's yeah that's soonish
they're doing an event they showed like
they're got like a thing going on
there's a tournament this weekend or
something cool cool
[Music]
see did you just say John Luke I did
that's that's John Luke's name hello
it's my name that's that's John Luke I'm
Ben we're here we're playing Halo it's
Friday
whoo wee baby are you ready for the
weekend I know I am I need to learn to
like stop myself from just saying things
and like ever a sentence never just
never ever stop never stop saying things
Ben oh god David did you Shadowrun then
I'll have to run that's true no other
option oh it's it's not Sean Luke's its
jean-luc I'm just really lazy when I
move my mouth so it might not sound like
it sometimes but yeah I don't care like
I've never cared it's it's like the like
the the Starfleet captain Jones my name
is jean-luc but people say John Luke I
say John like sometimes I don't care I
just I've long stopped trying to correct
people on my name it's it's fair people
say Jean luck Jean look yeah people have
said Jean luck they look they look at my
name there would be they say Jean luck
and I go what kind of monsters with my
parents be if my actual name was Jesus
sound like sounds like an x-men name my
name is my name is Jean luck my
superpower is I'm lucky all the time
that's not a person's name now it's not
uh dang I've had fun mispronunciations
in my last name with this because it's
not yeah there's that sometimes people
just call me John which I don't like
that one yeah it's a full name yeah it's
a full name JL I'm okay with that
because you're abbreviating it and I'm
that one it was Jo still looking like
you're acknowledging no just yeah the
weird one that I've noticed recently and
I'm like is people ask me what my name
is and I say my name is John Luke and
people think I'm saying my full name so
they go oh hey John look no no
cuz they think Luke is my last name oh
no no no no no John Luke cuz otherwise
I'd go
John Luke psyche yeah Oh like I don't
want to save my full name every time I
reduce myself you stewards name do a
James Bond you just say ham Ben you
don't we say hey I'm Ben Jenko right
sure no no I don't yeah but I'm in
trapped what do I do
yeah Stevie unless what I do is I say hi
my name is John Luke
yes that's my full name please it every
time every time
Steve McKown comes in insects people
heck yeah
says I love that this hallo stream was
just about Cheryl run that game was dope
see Steven knew about Shadowrun we just
get all shy okay okay so Stevens got a
play at a run with us is what I'm
hearing
quake 3 arena multiplayer was very good
too yes we can play Halo together that's
what the stream is all about and play
right now the way we've got to set up is
right now we're playing the PC version
of halo combat Evolved and you can join
by entitlement to play this game oh one
of you doesn't have there's someone just
love how do they leave please come in
stalling come back yeah if if you would
like to play with us join our steam
group which is GameSpot official you see
the name right there there's also a link
down over here somewhere further further
down on the screen that you can see join
that up join the chat and then right
click join on Stardust Crusaders who is
jean-luc in in the in the chat yeah okay
I'll give it a couple minutes I want to
see if more people join that one person
who wasn't able to join all you got to
do is is install the halo yeah
it's weird that it doesn't make you do
it through steam you have to go into the
game and then click it and then it
installs it yeah it's weird
it's an odd setup odd but it's an 88 big
team I agree David also says listen I'm
in a niche games shed run and phantom
dust phantom dust is another one yeah
they dubbed the like out like a remake
re-release of that like not too long
they re-released it and then on top of
that they were working on a full remake
but then that kind of fell through yeah
okay like the it's which publish is
which developers and then I don't think
that thing's dead dang it's not letting
me join let me uh let me hop out let me
see if I need a to maybe I'm like a
little adjust the thing moving thing
around you should be able to join just
join it on me mmm
[Music]
got the theme the music halo is always
so good it's so good
wanna be a new Megaman game I want to
see Mega Man Legends 3 happen we need to
get our boy off of the moon and Capcom's
keeping them up there
oh the HD release that's free on Xbox
one and PC and the multiplayer is also
up on it back you just play a whole
bunch of fun niche games
[Music]
so they're having an issue mmm
interesting not able to try everyone
else is able to join though hmm strange
maybe restart the game not our game but
maybe try restarting your game yeah I'll
pop out and I'll go hey we're going to
say hello okay take it back to halo
hoping this can run on low-end pcs I
feel like it's gotta be able to it's now
know what should I know what's going on
I'm like the like under the hood but
it's halo 1 yeah you would assume it
would
that's true - there is a new amnesia
game coming out they just announced that
this morning so that'll be interesting I
was never very good at amnesia oh that's
cool or about that I like the first one
I never finished it
second one I heard wasn't very good I
don't play it but I love yeah amnesia
they fix lot
I love soma yeah and and ii amnesia
wasn't made by the same people wasn't
made by a fractional fictional
frictional fractional I forget the one
of those the studio that made em easier
one didn't make em need you to I think
that was maybe but I like I forget the
name of the studio that made two but
they made they went made soma and now
that current back to you amnesia three
so I'm like let's get it I love the
David just said oh no is halo not
working at the shame of this turned into
a shadow run stream for real oh okay
they were havin easier the multiplayer
wasn't updated i like installed both and
then when i try to join the multiplayer
it was like no you're gonna install the
multiplier and i went back in and then
it just like i just we couldn't the
multiplayer and installed like instantly
so i had to do that for me too
okay so maybe I just make a weird like
trippy thing well hopefully you'll be
chillin still pretty quick wait for you
that's okay Hemme is my favorite joke to
make about it was a nickname it's it's
right there I gotta do it what it
outside a shot a run what would be like
the niche multiplayer game you would
want to play Anarchy Reigns cool that
was an easy answer I just want to play
in our key rains all the time other ones
though mine is a Sanskrit Brotherhood
multiplayer oh yeah some some good
Assassin's Creed multipe I really like
Assassin's Creed Wolfenstein enemy
territory it's not really niche but no I
don't know how many people in this sense
I'd it's not something like easily
accessible like yeah you have to do a
little bit of work to get that running
but it's so good a good time now it's so
good and it's free it's a free video
game
Team NZ 4 all right I want to play the
the Ubisoft remake of turtles in time
I'm gonna start the game up just keep it
going but you should really join me game
yeah there we go there we go got in in
the last second we're working a work
excellent uh I actually put up with that
new be soft remake of turtles in time Oh
Lots because I love turtles in time that
much it's it's not the best beat him up
Oh buddy did I have a good time miss
those old Ninja Turtles beat-em-ups yeah
last ninja turtles game was that
platinum one which wasn't very good yeah
which I watched Joey play that in the
office and everything like it's looks
bad yeah that hurt me a little bit right
for the sniper rifle I loved it you
immediately killed these plasma rifle
starts or I don't know I feel about that
yeah I should have changed that I mean
if it were pistols or anything people
would just be doing that all the time
salt rifles though that's the gym that's
the jam cuz I think it actually it's a
little more fair oh man this map I feel
so old now do battle creek was a great
map it is a great map it's still a great
or still plant we're playing in 2020
there's also I think Battle Creek was in
I think it was and maybe I don't know if
it was in five but it was they did it up
until reach I believe as well like it
was in it was in June and it was in
reach yeah I liked Battle Creek because
I remember playing at LAN parties back
home and being excited because there is
a town not too far away from where I
grew up called Battle Creek oh I was
like oh they named them map after the
city that's not too far away that didn't
but it was kind of a cool thing
what if they named the city after the
map after the math I'd be way into that
also I didn't really like comprehend the
fact that like there's a
called Battle Creek Battle Creek USA
that's the one you don't have any merch
like shirts to buy actually we did have
a merch store a few years ago I don't
know if it's still up we had a thing
going for III like two years ago to I
don't know if we have like a permit on
top that's what I was talking about it
was still around for a little while do
you want to look at that up actually a
curiosity that could take a look I'm too
afraid to work there's someone looking
up on my phone yeah
but we did have one we were selling like
potato mode t-shirts which is really
cool
[Music]
it's nice I found a red bubble shop
called GameSpot that has a bunch of ex
play shirts and gamer memes sick I don't
think this is us you go to the game spot
site here I've and I think I might go
find it okay Bob with movers I'm sick
yeah all right I'll look it up cuz I'm
actually just curious now well alright
no-ho-ho I saw that super-combined
coming from a mile away
I need to get we get like a something a
little better than this yellow no hold
on
two can play at that game come back
whoo
I hear you behind me no thought I can
scoop past you
dang so I'm not even warmed up anymore I
need to like I need get my business
sorted out ghek Rooney's
Oh can you not like dang can't find it
hey there's enough anymore you can't you
can't we had one at one point though you
can't tell if rank people anymore I
don't know when they changed that but I
don't like it no no no no no my murder
you stole my murder from me and then
also my life never might need to change
the the loadout wait wait I found the
link oh no it doesn't exist anymore
dang bummer I can take it back if you
want yeah let's do I keep blame Oh keep
talking to people you've got your flow
going so yeah I guess long long answer
we used to have one we currently don't
don't offload bring that back yeah it
was like a fun experiment I think should
make some merch by mode you want look at
merch what do you wanna buy yeah well
how many different uh community Friday
shirts do we need to make that's the
real question
I'll print them out myself lights please
yeah grenades are an important part of
playing Halo they're saying that to me
though not to you d fair I was yeah
see I would really like to do after this
like a bigger team battle thing yeah we
have hopefully enough people now we're
five oh there we go that game spot
Shadowrun crossover shirt there you go
Oh get uh you and me done in the style
of our favorite Shadowrun characters cat
wanna be the elf there you go
uh I'll be that that big scaly guy I
guess other the troll yeah the troll
okay
I'm not gonna be the rebel the rebel elf
not the Corporal there's no corporate oh
no get out of here with that but anyway
please buy our merch yeah no I'm sure
it'd be a thing that we'd probably talk
about at some point cuz it is kind of
cool to like I've got like an old beanie
from something that just has a GameSpot
logo on it and it's the other beanie I
wear that's not this one oh yeah so like
we're in hats because I don't know how
to take care of my hair okay let's see
if we can get a few more and if not
we'll just keep we'll just keep going
yeah with uh some bigger stuff so we've
we've been going for about an hour now
too so if you guys want to get in this
is the last half hour at the last 30
minutes yeah GG boys out we might be
losing someone thank you for playing if
your head now
unless I was just saying GG like good
game which case maybe a hold of GG uh a
big team battle
what kind of yeah they'd they did pop
out uh rat race rat race ir ares have
that remake of that movie where john
cleese gets really upset while
smashmouth has a concert for charity
it's like a fever dream but it's a good
fever dream I feel like God by something
jason says they're on their way fifteen
minutes so let's downloaded I know
so hopefully NIH in for for at least
that last fifteen but again don't worry
if you'd if you didn't make it in for
for this one but I'm sure will play halo
again what not kill out sure that's cool
oh yeah boarding action it's right there
it's right you wanna plan I mean do you
it's not a good map now okay well then I
run uh dude chill out
let's do let's do hardball chill out
item options
[Music]
here on the asari phone yeah that's
that's the ticket and guess no map
default yeah let's try a V a big team oh
well we could do oh you know what yeah
we could do online a v8 big team
actually let's do that that's taken away
yeah let's do that but that's way better
bring game session with you social game
like how halo 1 is so colorful I like
the colors in Halo 1 2 ok how do i oh I
need to go to beat v8 right uh it's
probably the one with a scorpion tank
I'm guessing heavies big team
battlefield right
I'd say hit it looks good to me I'm sold
all right let's do it game included in
category combination mmm what what does
it even mean oh maybe that's not an
option uh it might be like that doesn't
work for Halo your train changed too
what are the other options a v8 and
referral because it's like well you
can't do infection in your halo and game
presets dude big team battle well
doesn't seem to be okay and presets here
we go
big team battle here we go and then just
halo I like you cuz yeah they team
battle it'll probably just pick ya big
team battle in any of the other things
just take reach out of there and yeah
and then we hit play yeah
digits not match the rest of the party
oh maybe you don't have the update I
have the update so there was an update
for the whole game out and steam like a
little while ago like when uh maybe a
few hours ago it might be something that
Shaq but I'm not sure I mean seems like
I have everything I mean not like it not
like DLC but like an update update
cheese do I not have it possibly uh okay
well it's weird that it lets you play
with everyone not having the same match
data but not when you're trying to match
up and I hear let's do saw games for
sure on eBay listing last year oh man
that's weird
ah yes it's telling it close the game it
might be [ __ ] I should I hop out for a
second it did be easy to join backup you
okay sorry guys give us a hot second
we're gonna I'm gonna quit out and see
if I need to do an update this is this
is how games work man sometimes just
need to check this out man keys then we
got to see if it'll it'll trick the
update into going here check your your
download section really quick
don't ya
so got an update at some point I mean
you could do check integrity see if that
work uh yeah verify integrity and that
it'll just check it and be like oh yeah
not man you good hey Richie how's it
going good to see ya
I guess everyone who is playing with us
if you want to double-check that you
didn't have any updates either that's
kind of annoying though yeah right I'm
also kinda glad that they changed the
banner from just being reached to the
Master Chief collection now oh yeah I
think now that there's that because
before it was like it was just reach
you're only playing reach now you can
actually have multiple Halo games to
play so I think they changed it okay
look I got I got um I got an achievement
oh yeah when you uh my favorite thing is
when they unlocked it it's just this
like just spams at all
hey you unlocked 30 achievements since
like sick yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
appreciated that that's cool see I'm
guessing you have to download the actual
game settings to is true you have to for
some reason get the update out here and
then it also have like very heavy
initial install you have to install it
in the game too
but I know weirder things have happened
okay uh so you're you're all set we're
gonna this I'm fine so it might be
Papi's cloud files I just download from
those Cloud Strife files it might be
somebody else who was in our party who
wasn't updated awesome or maybe it's
just being glitchy it could be where's
Jess Jess is in Australia she's not here
this is the weird we're an SF um but
she's around she's doing stuff yeah
though it's the weekend for for them now
right yes so they're they're taking it
easy they're already kicking back on a
weekend house ex has their they're good
they're all set let's get this this room
all set up again yeah so let's get back
in here
we forgot people join back in til in
excellent see that's that's why I love
this steam group setup it's so good
rejoin everyone conjointly anyone can
join if you think you're lying you think
you're too good if you think you're too
bad if you just want to hang out and
have fun it's rare for ya now let's see
what's out did that maybe I'll try to
play some halo this weekend there's so
many games I want to play yeah that's
not enough time to do it in
what are you guys gonna be playing this
weekend out of curiosity so yeah you
guys have been asking us all these these
cool questions I feel like I should ask
you guys can you send me an invite
if you mean for my friends list sure I
might not accept it
but stories joining the game just uh
just drawing on me
yeah maybe all the right click on them
and send like a specific invite like in
the friends list I like this or not know
for being like weird like I could invite
them know for the game um no because cuz
I need you to join on me not so that I
can pick our game type unless you're
thinking that the game doesn't boo isn't
working right and like you have to join
mine Bob Jones doesn't he playing
Pokemon Jason says we be modding
Minecraft war pig is doing a Last of Us
run before two comes out Ritchie's gonna
be ripping and tearing through doom 2016
heck yeah oh yeah and you were talking
about going to to cod Lee Brandon
destiny next week would be a good time
ooh Jean my my dude Metal Gear Solid 4
hell yeah
love Metal Gear anytime I can get the
chance Metal Gear
[Music]
- uh-oh
well just wait a minute or two hmm
this bit where it builds by going back
and forth it's pretty good it stopped it
stopped here but above
oh gee he's just playing through metal
your solid four just to kind of play
through it again or is it funsies is it
your first time playing out your solid
four I want to know I want more info on
this Metal Gear run so since we at least
have a couple people I'm gonna test it
now they're worse okay let me stop for a
hot second yeah that people could join
but yeah looks like at least with these
people we can do it okay david says he's
already finished the new season of
Castlevania glad I got that oh my gosh
that this week out that's probably gonna
be think I do this weekend - I'm pretty
light that it's such a good show
it's really good I'll surprisingly so I
still want to watch the Dragon Quest
movie I haven't gotten around to it yet
well okay maybe I'll try to see if I can
find time but definitely time for
Castlevania got to see where my cool
vampire browser
oh we just start up a match I don't want
to like we're kind of running short on
time it's a go for it and if we have
time after this match is over we can
pick up someone else but like I said
don't worry if if you're almost done in
steam chat okay perfect well wait a
second perfect yeah we could we go hold
I will I will wait you to you it is
caught up on that 15-minute line where
people are saying they're downloading it
yeah yeah we appreciate you guys it's
not a it's not an issue to just hang out
and talk for a bit yeah that's fine like
the Dragon Quest movie I hear a lot of
people kind of going back and forth on
it but I hear most people saying they
enjoy it ooh what is a good movie
streaming service movie streaming
service a lot depends on what you want I
guess yeah you got to kind of look at
what they got exclusively and kind of go
for that yeah it looks is always like a
good catch-all sure he's got a pretty
good amount who's pretty good who is
probably better for TV than movies but
they'd still have actually a good amount
of movies um I actually still pay for
crunchyroll cuz it's not really a movie
streaming service but dojo ya know what
I have for cut you roll well actually I
pay for Verve and then crunch roles
included with it oh I think you get a
whole bunch of herb is pretty good
actually there's a lot of like like you
can watch Doug on it I like Doug a lot
it's my favorite anime really for not
animate the Disney show yeah hmm it's
it's a good time I like yeah I like Doug
no yeah wait wasn't Doug like Disney and
then it was Nickelodeon or the other way
around
yeah which networks I don't I don't
remember exactly but I know that all the
sounds are done with someone's mouth and
that's really cool some interesting
folly work
as a drain crest fan boy is it a thing
that's what I kind of hear a lot of
people who have played the game that
it's based off of
they changed like a really big story
thing for it so I don't I don't have
that frame of reference because I'm just
playing my first Dragon Quest game and
it's 11 mm-hmm
but I love 11 so much that I want to
play more so maybe uh maybe I'll hit it
up and not know and then I'll play the
game and be like that's how it was
supposed to be I get it now
all right just waiting on and talk about
deep dug lore only on our last got to
join okay I got one more where she asked
did you guys watch doom annihilation on
Netflix I did it's not as good as the
older one I did not I actually really
liked the older one okay we're waiting
on one last person and we're gonna start
up there it is yo let's do this punch it
idling players who's idling nope okay Oh
click kill past you not idle it's weird
that yeah yeah she's from matchmaking
when someone's idle whoo yeah this is
interesting I was every think of the
Final Fantasy demo it made Final Fantasy
you talk about the Final Fantasy 7 one
I'm assuming but it made me it made
Final Fantasy remake a big game for me
this year I was kinda just like oh I'll
play it whatever but now I'm like I want
to play it all right boys let's have a
good final match here okay I hope it
puts us on Blood Gulch or Sidewinder or
Sidewinder that picture right there of
just everyone on the scorpion tank with
a flag it's like PK low that gets me so
jazz oh you're like oh something up for
that yes is what I want 11 is so great
but my personal favorite is 9 I hear a
lot of people say like but it's 8 9 yeah
8 9 a lot of people say 4
because I've been in my dragon quest as
it were realizing that I really like
what Dragon Quest has set up I've been
asking a lot of people like hey I'm an
idiot and realized that I'm into these
JRPGs like way later than I probably
should have what one should I play some
hearing a lot of a lot of that hmm yeah
1111 so good it's just it makes me happy
all the time until the sad thing
happened and I got sad I didn't think
the Dragon Quest games could be sad I
was wrong
jeez I learned a hard lesson ah but wait
on one person now we're waiting on to
what do you think of the Last of Us show
who would be the best Joel talking about
that the road happened a couple years
ago didn't it yeah
well yeah I'm curious about it I I'm
less excited now that I know that it's
just a retelling a lot of the game I'm
like I don't see the point personally so
I'm almost I got it I've got I've got to
own up to it
I like the Last of Us through the
majority of its story the gameplay is
not the best but it's not bad sure um
but it had me all the way until the end
god I did not like that
I I'm one of the people who didn't like
the ending to the Last of Us and it kind
of made me just be like that it's just
it's my weird thing with it but I I'm
like it's not gonna keep me from playing
Last of Us part two I'm gonna play the
heck of sure sure and see what happens
but I was just kind of like being what
why did you do this to me I love that
ending
yeah I can I can also understand why
people like it I can understand myself
wouldn't like it
but it's it's interesting but as far as
who would be a really good Joel a
younger Kenny Rogers and on a Heuer
Kuebler Owen Wilson Jack Black
uh what other bad answers can I give cuz
I can't think of any good one
Rob Schneider there you go oh man killed
me backs and it happens sometimes
hallo one physics are hilarious uh says
have any insight or rumors about hallo
infinite no I wish I did I wish I knew
more about that game outside of the
trailers and like that weird screenshot
leaked that happened a while ago that
people don't know if it's real or not I
don't know what to make of it all of
them man grappling hooks might be cool
inhale oh yeah I like the idea that but
no II we don't have any insider info on
it I know it's a Halo game yeah we know
it's a Halo game we know Master Chief is
there we know basically everything that
everyone else knows off of the trailers
that have come out you're in for a heart
wrenching when you play eight then oh
I'm ready for it messed me up Oh Hugh
Jackman as Joel would be pretty cool I
can see it Hugh Jackman he's a really
good actor and I don't really think
about it much but like he plays a lot of
American characters and he is Australian
and doesn't let his accent slip ever
yeah which is there's a lot of actors
were they they let it slip in moments
yeah it's damn impressive I've gotta go
thanks for the stream have a good
weekend thank you for hanging out
Brannon it's always good to see you and
we're glad that you could hang out as
long as you did and I hope you have a
great weekend as well oh my god ah known
the banshee would have been right there
that's funny
who can't join just missed out oh that's
no good no I mean like we said we're
gonna be playing Halo a whole bunch more
later on like this this isn't the only
time we're ever gonna play halo halo is
definitely in our stable of returning
game
it is just because it's easy to get
people into and it's fun a lot of people
like it well we'll definitely come back
once Oh sniped once to comes out on PC
will definitely come back for that yeah
you can guarantee it you can count on
next week not much new happening that's
not his fault which is there's some
connection stuff happening or something
it's a big team battles too much for
them dude that's those wonderful though
uh I look the other ones multiplayer is
very nostalgic it's not as good you
can't even blow up war dogs it's like
the weakest of the MALDI players yeah
in my opinion it's it's like it's like
playing Mario vs. Capcom 2 competitively
it's fun but it's not serious
yeah yes and that's expect that's a good
way to put it like it's it's fun it's a
good time I rather play it over for
because I think for is it's just a bland
or definite but or I probably in over
five but it's like it is yeah it's not
it's not balanced it's not gonna be like
serious or competitive it's just fun
goofing around yeah what's cooler than a
gun with a digital display that's a very
fair point
David Digital splicing cuts are so rad
it's true how do they get them in there
how do they make that work there's so
much technology all put into one thing
is it out yet yeah this this was like
Wednesday just dropped out of nowhere on
Wednesday yeah Wednesday or Tuesday it's
I think it's 15 10 15 bucks for the game
by itself sounds about right uh but I'd
still say get ready for the whole thing
getting the Master Chief collection is
definitely the better path
I'm surprised you didn't Mele I hit the
wrong button actually what happened
I hit B bumped to the bumper
you know this map isn't the best no I'm
kind of bummed I'm going out on a bit of
oh I don't I don't think any of the
gearbox maps are particularly great yeah
that gets a nice that they put them in
here is like you know it's the complete
it's everything but it's my Caesar not
these ain't in my opinion yet this looks
like someone played Unreal Tournament
and was like that bridge map that oh
yeah let's do that but for halo and then
not facing worlds or what uh what's the
name yeah I don't remember the name just
been so long but I picture it in my mind
we should play Unreal Tournament 2004
what would that be fun fun mum yeah the
games on Steam it's cheap
I'm sure the servers are still available
oh they have to be and also I just miss
Unreal Tournament I do too
so we got some people were throwing
around quake earlier I was definitely
more of an Unreal Tournament person than
a quake person but I respect both yeah
we played quick champion as a fair
amount couple of years ago run here like
a year or two ago that's a good way to
put it if I don't remember a halo map it
probably wasn't good yeah that's a good
way to put it for sure unless you played
too much and got forced onto it and
you're like yeah not about it back and
clean heck yeah welcome back the last
five minutes in the stream right now
mm-hm probably the last match cuz yeah I
think we're gonna call it here do you
want to see it all the way through or
let's see it all the way through I mean
it's it's subtle go a couple over to
finish it heck yeah over time it is a
bummer we kind of ended on a black map
yeah I think it's more of a competitive
map yeah I mean it's cool that you could
try to just like design something to be
more competitive but it's it doesn't
have like a good lane set up I think
yeah I just
I'm not I'm so hard for me to put in
words but there's just something about
all the gearbox maps that I just don't
feel as good like for every gearbox map
there's just a I would just rather play
one of the Bungie ones yeah and you can
you can see what they're trying to do
something good though they're trying to
yeah appreciate that they were trying to
add new stuff but like I just don't
particularly care for any of them um are
we gonna see any new cyberpunk gameplay
anytime soon if I knew I would tell you
in a heartbeat but I kind of hope it's
it's those things it's very few flanks
yeah it's yeah it's there's a couple of
the side and flanks I was gonna get up
there so that's the problem it's three
lanes but it's three lanes way separate
grades they're basically in three
different zones yeah they're like really
far away lately so he's like really long
hallway it takes a really long time to
walk yeah
but hey look at those textures Oh
surprise they were waiting in the garage
for you the whole time
want to see more cyberpunk Keanu I want
to see more cyberpunk too but I also we
were talking about that earlier I feel
like I'm already in on that game and I'm
gonna play it regardless like yeah they
could show any amount of gameplay and it
wouldn't like move my hype for it
anymore because I'm already hyped up ah
I'm just I have a fun time with that
game I think I'm excited for for
Baldur's Gate 2 cuz it's got like you
can't plate though Scott well it's true
it's gonna be stank on it I'm really in
a divinity that'll be a cool thing I'm
stoked for that
Oh doom eternal comes into the chat and
says very good I agree yeah I am for
your game mr. doom eternal I'm waiting
for you to come out so I could play you
please come out soon well not get him
he's got jumped by the guy in the back I
don't think that sniper rifle guy hit
you like that much at all
that's that do me turtle that's it I
wish they'd do something for Anarchy
Reigns for Ben's sake I appreciate that
you're looking out for my my mental
state but I don't know if they're ever
gonna do anything for for Anarchy Reigns
I'd kill for like an HD remake or just
like a here's a steam release of it so
you can play it if you want to like just
something so I still listen to those
soundtracks ah
the closest thing bleeding-edge that
we're getting real soon I just listened
to the Anarchy Reigns soundtrack when I
play that that works out pretty well
yeah they're adding more soundtracks
thank goodness so we had gameplay that
went up recently that I was like ah cool
recent gameplay let's let's take a look
at this I'm still in that music in the
background I just didn't understand it
just wanna halo 2 I feel that Cody
I like Willis official trying to appeal
to the to the other team saying like hey
we're in a live stream please let us win
I love this top effort I appreciate it
who is sniping me I need up now my god
like I just can't you can't hate them
that it's it's the way that's designed I
don't this is a bad man I'm gonna be is
is a terrible map it is a very very bad
that's okay
almost done do you think Naughty Dog
will eventually add multiplayer to
lesson was to if they to will it be game
of the year again ah
I appreciated the multiplayer and Last
of Us a lot because it was one of those
like really kind of unique modes
but uh I don't know I donno if they'll
add it it'd be cool damn it
there's ready for you man he knows it'd
be cool if it did add it later on but
I'm sure that game will still be really
good even if it didn't have its
multiplayer added later on the way I'm
I'm excited to play it excited to see
where where those last of us people go
what they get up to
I guess no steam go oh there oh no I'm
sorry zilch master it's more like the
the mulch master now because you ran him
over
oh no for sailing like last was
multiplayer because it had that crawling
mechanic and grew on me and Anna
plumbing it loving it yeah I really
liked the multiplayer it was definitely
one that like you put a lot of stuff
into it you got a lot of out people who
are very good at that we're very good at
it I wasn't one of them but I had a good
time playing it either way that's an
appreciation got it nailed it he got
that that betrayal respawn timer yep
Ziya CH plays it so now we know
a some functional April release I'm not
sure I'd no no no I can't push back at
September now
yeah it's that's an end of your deal
which deal that's fine let him take her
time on it sure I trust them the girl be
DLC for last I was too late for the
first game I feel like that they'll
probably be open for more yeah at least
something I don't see a reason to not to
not do it but I'm also not the people
damn it ah would you ever give a sniper
secondary no no I picked it up it's like
trying to find them but then I got
sniped ghost does look really promising
the more I see that came out that last
trailer looked really cool
you ever play halo custom edition yeah
custom edition is the jam a fair amount
a long time ago yeah heck I even played
a halo 2 Vista me too
just cuz it had achievements tied to it
and it was a way for me to double up on
achievements for a game I already knew
all this stuff put this map equal to my
butt yeah hey man don't talk smack about
your butt like that
dang have a good but it's just Nero's
big brother yeah that's a that's a fair
take what you say did you did you do the
thing on Halo Vista where you could just
go into the command console unlock all
the achievements I heard about that but
that was all so I think we're who was it
that uh like from from a game website
someone went into like the game library
and took a copy of fallout 3 and
borrowed it for PC and boosted their
achievement score using the console
command so unlock all the achievements
there's a big deal where they're like
alright you got a lot to do this anymore
and they were like articles written
about it I forget where it was or who it
was but I remember that being a thing
with all three yeah and after hearing
about that I couldn't do like I couldn't
bring myself to cheat on stuff I I don't
even have the
our game on my achievement list because
I was very serious about like my
achievements have to be all [ __ ] and
they all have to be alright guys well
Wildmon sorry we ended on kind of a
bummer of a map but we really appreciate
you joining us
yeah and playing with us it was a very
good time yeah it was really fun time
and we definitely want to do more with
you in the future whether it's halo or
any other game they were playing now
sure we're doing next week there are a
couple options you could maybe try to do
a granblue but that's kind of you
granblue we could do we could do destiny
could do destinies new season comes out
next week and every Don with they're
bringing back trials which starts next
Friday there you go technically do
trials if we wanted we might be you
figure it out yeah what would make the
most sense but we'll see you guys next
Friday for us specifically otherwise you
can check out streams every 2 p.m. a
specific time every weekday every week
to hopefully purger we'll be back yeah
I'm feeling better and you'll be able to
see her next week as well until then see
you guys next time good bye have a good
weekend
[Music]